Let's now look at the solution for our N-Bit history predictor quiz.
We said that we want to have an N-Bit history predictor 2-bit counters per
possible history and we need 1,024 entries like that. And now we want to
compute the cost for these predictors, how well they do on the N N N T pattern,
and also how many of the 2-bit counters do they actually use in the NT
repeating pattern. The cost can be computed as simply the size of the history,
plus we need 2 to the nth 2-bit counters for each entry. And
if you compute what this is,
it amounts to 532,480 bits. So this is around
half a megabit of predictor stuff for just 1,024 entries.
With N equals 16, we're talking about
134,234,112 bits. So this is many,
many megabits worth of predictor stuff. Again, for the same number of entries.
As you can see, this is probably not a realistic predictor at all. And
even this one probably you don't want to spend that much harder on
just branch prediction. Let's now see how well they do on the N N N T pattern.
This is a pattern of length four, so anything that has N equal three or
more will handle it well. So from that perspective, all three of these will
do well. These two will do well on even longer patterns, and
finally how many of those two big counters did we have are we actually using for
the, not taken taken not taken, taken. Think about it this way, for
the N equals 1, when we need to predict the taken branch.
We have a history of just 0, because it's a single bit history.
When we need to predict the no taken branch, we have a history of just 1,
so we're using both of these. When we have N equals 4 and
trying to predict this not taken branch, our history is 0 1 0 1.
When we're trying to predict the taken branch, the history will be 1 0 1 0.
When we're trying to predict the next not taken branch, the history again,
will be 0 1 0 1. So as you can see, really, we will only be using
entries 0 1 0 1. And 1 0 1 0. So we're still using only two
of the 16 2-bit counters. If you look at the 8th-bit history,
the history will just be 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 and 1 0 1 0 1 0 1 0 here. So
we will still be using only 2. Of now, 256 2-bit counters.
So, we are now using less than 1% of the counters we have in each entry.
And finally, for this history, you can see the trend here, we will be using
only two 2-bit counters of more than 65,000 that we have in each entry.